[Music]
all the people from Barranquilla who have danced
know that the public
allows the peak to bring all kinds of
music to the people of
Barranquilla live with the most popular, make it
simple
[Music]
my name is junior
I am a guest Antonio Gallo Serrano
owner of Korean with me and I am
technician in brick electronics before peaks
of water cabins from 40 years ago and
supporting vi cotterill culture a whole
peak is a large sound equipment that
brings joy to a dancing audience through a person who plays
music
the game consists of its amplifiers
of power that gives its nest to the entire
parliamentarian perhaps among the booths
the sound that we heard a little
would cost more or less 30,000 okay
we started by hand between 2 with 22 for
the average
[Music]
at the peak it emerged they were making their
requirements small  and they have already started
taking it in the car from party to party
due to the limitation of sound, which is already
very small, we are going to make it bigger
then the most g  rande and in that they are to
attend to asier
where logical psychedelia is very historical
because it is exposed that if we are going to play
music that is happy we can see it with
black and white colors there in the back because
it would go according to what we are
putting the drawings differentiate the
teams
So I think that in this case the
drawings are what gives life to the
[Music] team,
which is a family tradition that has
come from year to year for 38 years
more or less,
we believe that we have a
cultural responsibility to continue maintaining this is
what  we like to listen to good
music the most
and whose about the vice bonus to continue
with him
I am proud of him